ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show the patagonia papers are out
and there's going to be hell to pay
this one we're not taking lying down the
panama papers we took lying down
slouching some of us lying down many of
us
uh leaning against a wall maybe but
we're not taking these lying down
something must be done and i'm we're
gonna do it
the pandora papers by the way pandora
the periwinkle papers are here and they
are making everybody
because most people when we're we're
home in our houses we go these
billionaires are they're
doing things on the up and up that's
right that's what i think i think when
someone makes a billion dollars for the
most part they're honest about
everything
and now
these papers
have shown us that many of these people
if you can believe it are fibbing
they're concealing
a wide array of assets
through shell companies
they have
multiple properties they have streams of
capital that are not being taxed
and it's gonna end
tonight
many of you are sitting at home going
what are
the panorama papers
what are they why do i care
does it matter to me it does because now
now you have the evidence
king abdullah
just to give you an idea
king abdullah that's right
this guy's full of it
listen to what king abdullah is doing
king abdullah i do not want to get all
the celebrity news thank you i just want
to read about king abdullah
go up again okay okay
these are king abdullah's secret malibu
properties
okay please go up
pandora papers reveal
royal taste
in oceanfront properties from modern
palace to bee cheek
what's great about this this is a real
estate website the real deal
they're
they're reporting
you know that a lot of people are
cheating
at the game right this is this is part
of what the pandora papers are revealing
that people are
taking money
uh and and not using it
to
better the lives of their people
or they're not paying into the tax
system
and they are they're using these uh
illicit not always illicit but some of
them are illicit streams of capital
and
they're using them to purchase real
estate in cities like london
new york
um
california and god help us austin
probably soon
so now the three cliffside drive homes
perched side by side are combined 22 000
square feet and offer commanding views
of the pacific ocean bought for 70
million over a three year period their
ownership remained a mystery to
neighbors in the exclusive point doom
section of malibu i bet the neighbors
went who
lives here
the largest one a 12 000 square foot
mansion is registered to an address in
switzerland another a four-bedroom villa
was purchased by a company in the
british virgin islands and the third a 7
600 square foot grand european style
estate was acquired from a delaware belt
based llc
the high-end properties are among more
than a dozen that king abdullah the
second bill bin al-hussein of jordan
who's i live with
uh purchased through shell companies in
the us and abroad revealed in this
week's massive leak
of financial documents known as the
pandora papers
um
the malibu homes were purchased between
august 2014 and september 2017. king
abdullah has also been going ahead with
a plan to demolish one of his existing
homes and build a much larger one
every time you see i'm not blaming all
arab billionaires here but let me just
say
uh when they do build things they're not
really concerned
with um
you know
how shall we say the style of the
neighborhood
can we say that
can we say that a lot of the arab
billionaires
like to get big and bold with the home
design they don't really value
continuity
again it's just that's an aesthetic
critique for me it's an aesthetic
critique
um
in some ways the king's desire to remain
anonymous is unremarkable the rich
famous and powerful have long plunged
millions into choice homes while
utilizing layers of shell companies to
hide their dealings it comes as no
surprise says compass luxury broker ron
nguyen
the desire to hold the true identity can
be so great that an agent working on a
sale may not know the actual buyer many
of them don't
for example when i bought my house in
texas i
had convinced
my realtor that i was someone else
because i did not want to for her to
know that it was actually me
so i had convinced my realtor that i was
megan mccain i had gone
into megan mccain wig
the whole thing and it was you know
pretty seamless
i was not called out
so now here's the deal
congress and aren't they powerful these
the congress
i have a lot of faith in the congress i
do oh yeah there they just get it done
don't they
congress which has what a 15 approval
rating in our own country
is now going to they're cracking down on
these hidden purchases it's congress
versus king abdullah hmm
who do you have
i'm i gotta be honest everything's about
gambling now who does dave portnoy have
what's the sports book say congress on
one hand uh full of a bunch of slobs
from minnesota and uh king abdullah bin
aziz hussain
al-money
who's going to win that war well let's
see
let's see if king abdullah and by the
way all of our financial establishment
real estate establishment
um and a lot of congress versus
you know people like katie porter who
seem like lovely people who go there and
she's got you know mayonnaise on her
thing and she's like i made lunch for my
kids today and
you know hey mr diamond jamie diamond
would it surprise you to know that
everybody that works at your bank eats
food they find on the floor
and he goes well miss porter
um that would surprise me and would it
surprise you to know that the food they
found on the floor is not even warm
it would it would i would think they'd
pick it up right after it fell well that
is not what they're doing sir they're
waiting many many hours to eat the food
it's cold
so we have katy porter on one hand and i
like her because she seems like someone
who throws breast milk like water
balloons and breast milk at a ceo and i
think we need more of that she's just
fun she's a mom she drives a minivan and
she just shits on these billionaires i
would like to see katie porter versus
abdullah bin aziz hussain muhammad
whatever his name is i don't know i'm
not being racist i can't remember his
name
katie porter on one side and then the
king of jordan on the other it'd be fine
excuse me mr muhammad you like malibu
don't yeah yeah i don't have too much
time to go to the beach because i have
three kids that are always nagging me to
make their lunches okay
okay so i heard you have three you have
three properties in malibu yes see the
thing is king they do is probably very
charming
you're just very nice well
i heard they were purchased by shell
companies now would it surprise you to
know king abdullah that many people are
using shell compass is not a bad katy
porter by the way many people are using
shell companies as a way to conceal the
amount of money flowing into real estate
that are illicit streams of capital
would that surprise you
yes very surprising
but for years the malibu properties had
beguiled the king's neighbors and local
government officials i'm the local
malibu government who is that some
stoner
who's that
the p the local government in malibu is
like all poor people that have lived
there forever and they just couldn't
afford
they couldn't afford to buy anything
there now and they're just like whoa
he's [ __ ] the beach man king some
king is [ __ ] here dude whoa
you got to realize that the people that
have money in california are very stupid
and because in new york you make money
you know you go to good schools you're
raised in a family that cares uh in
california you make money on only fans
or being like a music manager or
whatever that's those are the industries
in in california whereas new york it's
like finance um you know uh insurance
real estate tax conventional banking and
in los angeles you have like uh only
fans uh music manager
uh
f tat face tattooed ragamuffin
you just see like a kid with face
tattoos
and he's a trillionaire and you don't
know how and his name is like gucci
provolone or something
so
what is the point of i'm i'm struggling
i read about the pandora papers and i've
struggled to find a point in all this
because what are we supposed to do are
we supposed to head down to malibu and
give the king the what for
is that the point here i'm i'm
struggling to find the point of what's
going on by the administration is
cracking down on for-profit schools that
made false promises about students
futures and drove them into debt sorry
this has nothing to do with that i
clicked on the wrong article here we go
brian's also cracking down on this this
week though biden is biden is cracking
down this is the theme of the week
cracking down we're cracking down yeah
the president says the irs needs two
bits of information all the money that
goes into your bank account and all the
money that comes out i don't love that
what's this guy doing
he's cracking down he's cracking down on
on the good american people about their
tax cheating there's no snooping around
most people in this country like not
have a ton of money do we really need to
analyze the tens of dollars going in and
out of people's bank accounts and on top
of this they're asking for everybody's
stimulus is back if they if they prove
they couldn't find employment and stuff
so they're asking people to give back
thousands and thousands that'll work
that's a good idea that'll work
that's like if you ever lent someone
money then you're like hey so if you you
know if you ever
if you ever want to put some of that
together yeah that's going to work
so biden this corpse
is out there
they're trying to just because they need
money now we're about to default the
country is about to default for the
first time and they need money so
they're cracking down on your venmo
transactions who did you have that pizza
with and who did you pay
so the government's on the on track to
default for the first time ever which is
bad because we're we're a good you know
we have a good credit rating and it'll
[ __ ] us up and janet yellen who's a
terrifying looking human being who what
if she's the chairman of the federal
reserve that's correct and they just
trot her out when there's bad news to be
had don't they well she's the treasury
secretary she's like she's like grandma
but grandma's always got bad news
she's always coming out with a cancer
diagnosis you know yeah that's grandma
grandma comes out she's like she just
looks like the type of person who walks
in the middle of dinner and goes stage
four
at best case in aggressive stage three
oh sorry grandma i'll be fine
you know
i'll be fine they may have to chop my
old tits off i may have to shave my head
i look like that girl from that show you
watch what's that show stranger things
yeah i look like her but that's okay
don't worry about me
i'll just be here defaulting on the
national debt
with my cancer-ridden body
i don't know if she's had can i'm just
saying she looks like an old grandma
that comes in and drops a bomb yeah and
she has janet yellen on tuesday said she
believes the economy would fall into a
recession if congress fails to address
the federal government's borrowing limit
before an unprecedented default on the
us debt
so october 18 to the deadline it would
be catastrophic to not pay government's
bills for us to be in a position where
we lack the resources to pay the
government's bills yellen said during an
interview on cnbc's squawk box i like
that guy you know the fat guy from
squawk box i don't know get the fat guy
up from squawk box i like him what
happened to him squawk box squawk box
fat guy
image okay i'll just type in squat box
fat guy yeah what happened to him i
don't like the new guy squawk squawk box
fat guy
yeah where's he
is that him on the left yes what
happened to him
let me see it's this new guy i don't
like
where is the fat guy from squawk box i
gotta see uh
coasted by joe kernan becky quick andrew
ross sorkin i don't want andrew ross
sorkin get him out of here it must be
joe kernan that's right
maybe yeah joe kernan no
that's not he looks good there
what the hell photo is that
that's like me using a photo of tana
mojo
anyway so janet yellen
grim grandma let's call her grandma grim
yeah so grandma grimm goes on squawk box
with the reality which is that we don't
have any money left joe biden's trying
to take your money out of venmo
and uh so what what's the plan here they
were going to come up with some coin
they're really demonizing crypto we got
to get peter schiff have we made any
progress getting peter schiff on the
show i am in communication with um um
the the assistant of peter schiff but
right we don't really have the
capabilities this is financial news now
peter schiff i've been watching him for
the last year and every day he talks
about the end
i think he'd be a really good addition
the trillion dollar coin scheme
so uh
this is interesting
this is a a way to avoid
potentially defaulting
okay it says on tuesday the treasury
secretary yellen said uh
she does not intend to mint a platinum
coin worth 1 trillion to pay for the us
government's expenses if you're not
familiar with the platinum coin idea or
the hashtag mint the coin
boy we're at the end aren't we
um
the small army of coin easters who've
become a vocal point of economics and
financial circles since early 2010 you
might be saying what are you talking
about the short answer is that later
this month the u.s will exceed the legal
limit on how much outstanding debt the
federal government can hold the debt
ceiling
the senate republicans have agreed to
allow an extension through december and
that just sets up another confrontation
in a few months so to avert a global
economic catastrophe um some observers
have broached some interesting but you
know absurd ideas one of them is meant
to coin
and um
the treasury secretary could simply fund
the government by minting platinum coins
interesting in 2013 even u.s former mint
director philip deal agreed it would
work over the years influential voices
like joe wiesenthal paul krugman have
also promoted the idea but they did not
simply stumble upon this it was brought
to their attention by beowulf a blog
commenter and reply guy better known as
atlanta area attorney carlos mucha mucha
conceived of the idea in a short comment
on financer warren
mosler's blog
posted may 24 2010.
this is the comment curiously enough
congress has enough delegates
um
delegated to treasury all the signerage
power authority it needs to melt one
trillion
coin
even
numismatic coins are legal tender at
their face value must be accepted by the
federal reserve that catches it's got to
be made of platinum
do you know the balls of any president
who tried this that have platinum balls
so for one ounce coin
uh tsy would net only
uh 999.998
billion
so
yellen is not prepared to mint the coin
she doesn't want to mint the coin she
doesn't want to mint the coin so instead
uh joe biden and kamala harris will be
going through your zell and venmo
transactions to get the money back that
they gave you so you stop burning things
down
now that you've proven that you can go a
few months without burning things down
they feel comfortable asking for the
money back imagine in the middle of the
burning of the things down they're like
how about that money no one said that
but now that everybody hasn't you know
gotten frisky they're saying let's get
some of that money back
this fall as you get back into the swing
of things bespoke post is here with a
new season lineup of must-have box of
awesome collections bespoke post
partners with small businesses and
emerging brands that bring you good
stuff every month really cool unique
stuff
you get a new box every single month was
really cool that you can kind of custom
design but you're still surprised they
have you covered from autumn craft beers
to cozy threads camping gear essentials
box of awesome has collections for every
part of your life is a really great gift
for someone too not only for you but
it's a great gift for somebody who went
away to school or something get started
take the quiz at box of awesome dot com
your answers will help them pick the
right box of awesome for you they
release new boxes every month across a
ton of different categories it's free to
sign up and you can skip a month or two
or cancel any time each box costs only
45 bucks but has 70 worth of gear inside
plus with each box of awesome you're
supporting small business 90 of
everything that comes in your box of
awesome is from a small up-and-coming
brand
get 20 off your first monthly box when
you sign up at box of awesome dot com
just enter the code tim dillon at
checkout it's a really great way
to get yourself some really cool stuff
or give a friend some really cool stuff
for the entire year that's box of
awesome dot com code tim dillon for 20
off your first box
i got a box of pancakes how cool is that
i
they asked me a few questions
and i didn't even say i wanted anything
to do with food
i actually said i wanted to start hiking
but instead they sent me a box of
pancakes
pancake batter a griddle
vermont maple syrup and something called
sucker punch what is that it's a bloody
mary mix and bloody mary gave that to my
wife i literally said i want to start
hiking
and they sent me a griddle and pancakes
so they know you better than you know
you is my point
box of awesome perfect i love watches
i love them
you love them
i mean here's the deal we all want to
watch
how about watch gang have you heard of
watch gang i have you got to go to watch
gang dot com slash tim they're the
number one watch club in the world are
you a watch guy you should become one i
am they'll give a tag away every tuesday
a rolex every friday and a seiko every
saturday
treat yourself with up to 70 off retail
a plan for every price point keep every
watch all watchers are guaranteed to be
worth more than the price of membership
gang partners with small european
boutique brands as well as seikos of the
world so you get everything you get the
small bespoke watches you get the bigger
brand names get a watch whatever you
want it do you know how many times i'm
in my car and i want to watch
i got my hand on the
on the door and i look at my wrist and i
go i want a watch now
get one
get a watch whenever the hell you want
it
monthly quarterly
or whatever
swiss and japanese movements and all
watches
you need this is what i will tell people
people without watches are sus
especially if you're trying to look
successful you need to have a watch
everybody's got to watch i don't but i
don't have to but i have one now because
you do have one because watch gang sent
us watches i know now i'm going to win
i'm really starting to transition into a
watch person this is true because of
watch gang because of watch gang and the
fact that i i need to constantly project
that i'm doing okay
and one of the ways we do that is with
jewelry which i don't i'd look weird in
chains and stuff
right or like around the neck yeah yeah
but jesus piece
yeah maybe a basketball journal watch
around my neck
watch gang
because you're in a gang now but it's
not an illegal gang
it's a gang of watches
and what's good about that is
you can get many you need different
watches
there's a watch for when you meet your
girlfriend's family there's a watch for
when you go on a job interview there's a
watch for when um
you are sitting in a bar alone maybe to
meet a woman yes there's all these
different times in your life when you
need a watch there's a watch to where
when you're saying your final goodbyes
to someone who has a terminal illness
it's true you don't want to be too
flashy
what there's a one there's a watch for
that truly you got to pick the right
watch you don't want to walk in with
crazy bling
but you also don't want to go too small
right you want them to notice it because
it takes away some of the awkward you
know what i mean because no they will
turn around and go like i like your
watch you know and there's something
beautiful about that
go to watchgang.com now and use promo
code tim for 20 off all plans you got to
remember all of these companies that
support our show
not only do they have cool products they
love comedy and they support comedy and
they allow comedy to happen and to be
funny so if you support that go to these
companies and support them it allows us
to keep doing the show on youtube so
that is watch gang
w-a-t-c-h-g-a-n-g
dot com promo code ti-m to save 20
that's watchgang.com promo code ti
m i'm telling you right now it's
important to have watches
these these uh
these pandora papers
outline this
extra legal
way that a lot of people and i knew this
when i was a tour guide in new york city
i paid very close attention to real
estate new york and we talked about it
ad nauseam on this show when you have
lots and lots of money you have to do
things with it you can't just put it in
banks you can't just invest it you can't
be
constantly you know subject to
regulators and taxes you want to get
away from that and the way to do that is
come up with shell corporations
and put them in in places that nobody
really goes right or very few people go
the cayman islands delaware and then use
those shell corporations to purchase
real estate hide your ownership interest
evade taxes
do a little money laundering that's what
new york city is it's a vertical money
laundering scheme
look what the guy look what the ghetto
louis vuitton did with his yacht
this is a bernard i believe arnold or
something he's ahead of louis vuitton
and the pandora papers reveal he's got a
real nice boat
i wonder when these things get leaked no
one no one's gonna do anything
but it's just funny because this happens
and this happened 2016 2017 like 20 yeah
it happens like every single year then
the next set of papers will
not be papers anymore there'll be
photographs of these people with the
middle finger to you
bernard arnold bernard aldorn
yeah i was looking at his yacht he's got
a sick yacht okay
oh symphony yeah but this was something
again that got leaked in a pin to our
papers i don't know because you know
this is supposed to make you
angry at these people but i say you just
embrace it
and
you just
say hey
at least they're doing cool [ __ ] do you
want king abdullah to to like not do
cool [ __ ] if you were the king of a
country where you could literally kill
anyone you wanted
you could do anything you wanted you'd
be expected yeah bernard arnault
stealthily
slips out 30 million for beverly hills
house next door so all of these all of
these uh people in the pandora papers
things are coming out uh
you hear that
do they hear it now they probably will
hear the siren yeah
all of these people
are being outed as tricksters and then
you know
but they're cracking
they're
cracking down
do you see
they're cracking down so this won't be
going on next year
if i know um
if i know the the government they will
get a handle on this rather quickly and
they're going to reign in the rich
and make them do the right thing
what's interesting about the rich is
they never smile
until they're forced to smile like the
really rich not like you have a bmw i
mean like
the incredibly wealthy hate smiling
because i live in a building now with a
lot of very wealthy people albeit ones
who've kind of destroyed their lives a
lot of divorced dads and
young kids and you know
crypto punks but actual crypto punks not
the things they sell right um
and very few of them are smiling without
you know
some type of
uh help
now look at this yacht isn't this a
beauty it's a beautiful yacht this is
nice
that's it right there
how much
let's see here something crazy i read
about it oh this yacht website's down
they're not doing good i guess
they probably just put it down because
the pandora papers they're just like
just chill for a week
just take
the [ __ ] website down for a week
i wanted to find things out that would
surprise us you know
like i wanted to find out that like
like
through a shell company
like through a shell company
where his ownership interest was hidden
i wanted to find out that like sebastian
maniscalco owned like 20 private prisons
that would have been fun to find out
what are you doing they're bad they got
it down who cares
what are you doing with these government
prisons are you embarrassed
you go to the private prison let the
italians cater to private prison
but that would have been fun but it's
just the usual suspects
um yeah it's like elton john shaquille
oh yeah so he owns a luxury mega yacht
with 150 million
yeah he's got 93 billion so who's who's
in the pandora papers you said elton
john uh you should shakira yeah i got a
i got an article right here uh these
guys uh
look at look at these guys right here
these pandora papers taxis implicate
several celebrities including shakira
elton john julio iglesias swedish house
mafia and others oh ringo's stars bingo
star
let's go get these people
that's what saudi arabia did they locked
them all in the rich cult and tortured
them
why don't we do that we have a bunch of
rich cottons
what if we
for
a
purely this is a purely comedic exercise
okay but imagine this tomorrow you wake
up
and joe biden has
commandeered uh the ritz carlton let's
say in uh i don't know
wherever new york okay
dc
there's a ritz in dc okay and he has
taken over the ritz in dc
uh
in the dc ritz
and and and
and tonight while you're asleep
shakira elton john julio iglesias
swedish house mafia ringo starr
bernard arnault
everybody that is all of these people
they're kidnapped and they're driven
from their homes to the ritz carlton
where they are tortured mercilessly
and made to give up all their money
now again
wrong
perhaps
but
he would win re-elect like if he would
win re-election
because how could you
how could you say anything
like dude he tortured shakira yeah yeah
she's just getting you know like whipped
it's like squid games but he's just
torturing all these celebrities joe
biden
brought julio iglesias to the ritz and
caned him
until julio admitted
all the shell corpse and all the real
estadio
joe biden
and he's on video like mbs i think was
on video or something
he was like where he was like hey did
you read about any of that i better shut
up we're gonna get killed you showed me
a video of that but uh i mean there's
not much about that online there's not a
ton about it yeah there's there's not a
ton about it um there'll be a show on
netflix in a few years about it that is
the one thing the game show around here
it's like mbs and stuff we don't want to
cover yeah we're not even i'm agree i'm
not
i'm saying nothing negative
listen to what i am saying
understand what i am doing
i am not saying you did anything wrong
sir
i am saying if and again i would never
call for this but if kamala harris
wanted my respect if i found out she
locked up swedish house mafia in the
montage in laguna beach and tortured
them until they gave up all their money
i would phone bank for her
night of the beating details emerge of
riyadh ritz carlton purge but this is
kind of interesting it is yeah three
years on some of the saudi detainees
reveal what they say took place
in early november 2017 nearly 400 of
saudi arabia's most powerful people
among them princes tycoons ministers and
shakira were rounded up and detained in
the ritz-carlton hotel in what became
the biggest and most contentious purge
in the modern kingdom's history the
arrest shook the foundations of saudi
society in an instant turning uh
untouchable establishment figures into
targets for arrest statuses were
discarded assets seized and business
empires upended a conventional pact
between the state and its influential
elite was shredded overnight now leading
figures uh caught up in the detentions
have revealed details of what they say
took place
many of whom were stripped of fortunes
portray a scene of torture and coercion
and of royal court advisors leading
chaotic attempts to understand the
investments behind the wealth of the
king wouldn't it be great so imagine our
version of this
and it's just swedish house mafia you're
playing their music and the torturers
are going how is this we don't
understand how you make this much money
we don't get it
some of it is okay but most of it i
don't know
we don't get it
because that's what happened here
the saudi officials are going how do you
doing this how are you making all this
money
like they could they could bring ringo
starring and just you know put them up
on the rack and go
you were the least talented beatle like
by far
i don't understand george wasn't great
either but
the disclosures come in the third
anniversary of the purge and ahead of
the g20 summit in riyadh
this week and advocates
of the right to women to drive among
them but see that's what's cool saudi
arabia they know how to balance it
they'll do something like this then they
go let the women drive
look a woman's driving
wait you just tortured everybody she's
making a left look at her make a left
and everyone goes
she is making a left so what they did
and we don't need to go into every
detail here because you can get it and
you can read the order okay hold on i
like this
on the first night everyone was
blindfolded and nearly everyone was
subjected to what egyptian intelligence
calls the night of the beating i mean
what if biden just came out and said
this
like he said in response to the pandora
papers we kidnap
a swedish house mafia and we subjected
to them what we would call and you know
biden says it very calmly because uh he
called them the night of the beating
people were asked if they knew why they
were here no one did they were beaten
many of them beaten badly they were tied
to walls stressed positions and went on
for hours and all the doing the
torturing were american good old usa
so the interrogators arrived on the next
day so the first day is the beatings and
the torture and the next day the
interrogators
the detainees had by then but separated
into rooms in the hotel that a year
earlier had been the venue for the
launch of prison muhammad's ambitious
vision 2030 here's the thing with mbs i
i feel like i like him
yeah yeah he's great
well
there's people who've said negative
things but he's never done anything to
me i live in beverly hills and i'll say
this i like him
i think he's great
and i am not in any way
criticizing the saudi royal family they
have indoor lakes and they ride jet skis
on them
and i don't even care about 911. i don't
like finance people that much anyway
there is a misconception that they
turned up all knowing with pages of data
and information they didn't they
the interrogators knew very little and
they were winging it
they were hopeless on the offshore stuff
so basically this is what
you have two options yeah when your
pandora paper is coming
and obviously there's a third option
that involves like congress passing laws
you know but you know but you katie
porter's ferocious but you'd have to
have a bunch of katy porters you know
katie porter can only do so much she's
she's trying to do her best and make a
grilled cheese for everybody
um so what you could do is you could
lock everybody up in a hotel and beat
them
and torture them or you can just kind of
do what we've done which is write real
estate blogs about the houses they
bought
and go stunning modern chic
it's a stunning modern chic beachfront
complex that was not going on in riyadh
they were not talking about the stunning
modern chic complexes it was the night
of the beating
this is
this is these are the choices you can
have night of the beating yeah
night of the beating
or real estate blog stunning modern chic
many of the king's neighbors were they
were they were in a tizzy they didn't
know who lived there
um
many of those who came in
i'll tell you this man it's difficult to
know what to do
isn't it
it's hard
because mbs is sitting there and saudi
arabia does horrible things to
all kinds of people
um
but he's sitting there and he finds out
not to me
yet
and he's sitting there and he finds out
that people are
they're they're they're taking money
they're stealing they're doing kind of
what's written about in the pandora
papers that's right and
he goes
we're gonna have to have
a little bit of a talk
and we're gonna have to lock everybody
up in the ritz
and the party's over
and my my thing is if katie porter
god
if katie porter yeah
kidnapped
jamie diamond in a minivan
like in a lunch lady outfit yeah
like dressed like chris farley from
lunch ladyland if she threw jamie
diamond in a minivan
with a bunch of other ceos and took them
to like the four seasons
okay and
just directed their torture
i don't know that you'd
get anything out of it but
the pure aesthetic value of that to me
is not nothing
you know what i mean you'd be like oh
dude they mean business they're not
kidding around
there was a terrible shake-up in america
the elites were on the run
lunch lady and congresswoman
katie porter and i know she's like a
lawyer but she looks like a lunch lady
she does lunch lady katie porter
in the middle of making sloppy joes
kidnapped
jamie dimon
and a bunch of other ceos and brought
them to the four seasons hotel where
they were mercilessly tortured by
interrogators
and she's just sitting there she's like
where's the money
mr diamond
i feel like we've met before and he's
like oh there's a chain on a wall she's
like we've met before haven't we i
believe i asked you a question about how
people at your bank could make ends meet
i broke down all their monthly expenses
what and the guy's just hitting them
yeah i remember
well mr chairman i have a few more
questions for you do you have the time i
think you do
he's just chained up in a suite
at the four seasons hotel being
brutalized by interrogators and then
katie porter is like all right so mr
diamond
let's let's just
let's start by saying i'm your friend
and i think we both want the best for
america wouldn't you agree jamie and
he's like please stop this i'll give you
anything you want well i'm glad you said
that
because i have a lot of questions about
your bank
about
about your lending practices
about the money that you've paid to get
out of serious government inquiries so
i'm glad you're here and just
just lashings
and again i'm not saying it's the right
thing to do i'm just saying these seem
to be the choices these are we live in a
world of so few choices there's not much
to do when these things come out
so you either
drag all these people to a hotel and
beat and torture them or you just kind
of ignore it and you go bad boy
you're a naughty boy
you're a naughty buy are you being a
naughty boy in martha's vineyard i bet
you are there's not you know
poor jizzly maxwell's just sitting in
there poor just laying she's like all
these [ __ ] are you reading the
pandora papers
i've done nothing compared to these
[ __ ]
they probably treated her like a winch
when is her trial when is jizzling
maxwell's trial i believe it's november
and then we're gonna talk about
ivermectin for three hours
yeah it's november 29th so uh right
around uh right around thanksgiving
there
that'll be fun
oh a thanksgiving trial for drizzling
november 29th oh i like that huh
a thanksgiving party for jizzlane
maxwell
she's just in brooklyn just chilling our
friend have you seen have you heard
about the new alex jones doc oh no no
that i was going to be interviewed for
but i had kovid no no i don't know if
it's public yet oh okay but it might be
oh it's the woman who made um
the tfw yeah yeah tfw uh
you're not gonna get anything about it
yeah i don't think it's public yet yeah
i'll watch that should be interesting
they're screening it
i think it's called alex's war or
something there
they're screening it the um
[Music]
you know things are heating up with the
kids in the vaccine because now people
want to give the vaccine the
five-year-old i don't understand any of
this
um
i'm completely lost on this
um i understand certain kids have gotten
coveted and fared very badly but the
vast vast vast majority of children
easily beat cove the vast majority
they've suspended the modernist shot in
i forget which country for people under
a certain age because it was causing
myocarditis and problems like that
um
i forget which country uh japan suspends
1.6 million doses of modernish shot no
this was recently
oh scandinavians
yeah
yeah they're they're
they're just they're like hey man
and also scandinavia people aren't as
fat
you know what i mean like you eat your
pickled herring and you go on about your
day
they don't have like you know you know
drive-through barbecue troughs and you
know
they don't have like bouncy castle
pizza huts
yeah i mean they're just it's
scandinavia there are stoic people they
barely laugh they barely
you know they just they enjoy like you
know just light food a little like kind
of like
you know interesting
earthy sex a little like like staring at
a
at the water in the night during the
night you know and then i think a lot of
them aren't anti-depressants and stuff
as well but i don't know
um
because after a while you know the great
thing about america is you have the
highs and the lows and over there it's
just kind of a state like it's prozac
the country is kind of a problem but
they made a good point they're like kids
get over this stuff why are we giving it
to young people and they have an
increased risk of heart inflammation it
says for the madonna yeah it's the
myocarditis so this this this is kind of
this debate
is heating up about go to drudge drudge
had it uh there was a uh and i think
gavin newsom did a vax mandate oh
tesla's moving to austin by the way elon
musk moving tesla to austin texas my
favorite city
finland joined sweden and denmark in
limiting moderna kova 19 vaccine
um for people that were for men
um
okay hold on
they said that finland would instead
give pfizer's vaccine to men born in
1991 and later
so under 30. yeah
i don't know if these countries are
doing a ton of mandates though
i don't know that they are i think you
know i think in those countries people
just want to get vaccinated some of them
some of them are doing the mandate some
of them aren't
um
and now we have like
i told you i walked in somewhere my god
sounded like an ice cream parlor and the
woman's like how old is he
i'm like he's like one should oh a two
they gotta wear a mask it's like [ __ ]
what are you talking about where was
this this was here yeah an ice cream
parlor good lure but this is what i mean
about
people who go a little going nutty now
they're looking at a baby like what's
his deal that's crazy they're looking at
a baby like yeah what's his deal he's a
little vector of disease his name i'm
like man people just turn into nazis
overnight
overnight they turn into nazi it's not
even a process
where's your card
it's a lot but
you know there's also a lot of people
this country think that's a phenomenal
idea so
you know
what are you gonna do
tesla moving its headquarters uh from
california to austin texas the greatest
city in america elon musk is moving um
tesla
which is uh makes a silly car it's silly
um
and it is it's kind of for children
right
when i see teslas i go that's for a
child it's a toy it's not for an adult
when you get in and it's like fun you're
excited yeah it's
for a child
so he's moved his children's toy car
company
to austin texas and then he the cool
stuff he does is with those spacex
satellites remember we're in the
backyard with john shahidi and we
thought we were being invaded by aliens
yeah it was crazy yeah we're all just
sitting in the backyard smoking sticks
and then the tesla starlink satellites
went over uh our heads and we're all
staring at them like dude are we being
we thought we were being invaded
me and shahidi thought we were being
invaded by aliens because the ufo stuff
was ramping up yeah the news and yeah
john was like when they land what brands
will they align with i'm like i don't
know
i love john we miss him hopefully we see
more of them now that we're going to be
back in l.a but i'm still living in
texas and love texas i'm a full-time
resident and i have an apartment here
occasionally when i need to be here for
work truly i'll be in texas for the
majority of my life forever because i
love it
on a red dirt road
i'll be on a red dirt road
um
to be clear but we should do that in
austin by the way let's kidnap everybody
in austin and bring them to a hotel and
make them clean it
to be clear we will be continuing to
expand our activities in california musk
said our intention is to increase output
from fremont and the giga nevada by 50
if you go to our fremont facility it's
jammed but he added it's tough for
people to afford houses people have come
in from far away there's a limit to how
big you can scale in the bay area so
he's going to
uh austin takes tesla less time to build
a factory than to reach high volume
production musk said for example tesla's
shanghai plant was built in 11 months
but took a year to reach high volume
production he expects tesla's new plant
near austin will follow shanghai's
example
it's gonna be interesting texas
california you know tom segura and
christina talked about this they're
having a war texas california in a war
i mean austin's not gonna be cheap
either i know the bay area austin's not
gonna be cheap
here's the thing about texas california
new york will always be the king it's
just a reality new york always be the
king
it is what it is it's always going to be
the king
texas and california can vote can fight
each other for the secondary slot
all of the meaningful like new york has
all of our institute cultural
institutions
you know you know the east coast has a
lot of the academic institutions a lot
of intelligent people
um
there's a reason jeffrey epstein didn't
live in austin
do you know what i mean
there's a reason
but new york's always going to be the
king uh california and texas can fight
for number two
and uh and then florida are we doing
steve's ad today oh yeah you can go
right into it so we're going to talk
about florida
steve will do it from oviedo florida
he's a member of the nelk boys the nelk
boys are a group of uh internet
pranksters who don't make any money on
youtube they've been demonetized
because
they're wild they do crazy stuff they
pretend to drink and do coke in front of
the cops
and um
they go to colleges all over america and
get the kids
uh and i like this they say with the
kids stop the focusing on the politics
and the gender let's get [ __ ] up and
jump off a roof that's what college used
to be about sexual assault how about
somersault where we just
we jump off the house but that's what
they they do they go to colleges they
get people nice and revved up they get
people drunk and full send and they just
it's all about hedonism and it's fun
it's good for the kids a little
different you know
um so we're very proud to have c and i
like steve because he's kind of the
breakout star of the uh the nilk faction
there's a few other ones that kyle who i
like but he's he's serious you know he's
got a the business man he's the business
guy he's he's serious he seems like
he'll throw a woman down the stairs and
then there's celine the other guy who i
like but could turn on the country at
any minute so you got to watch him
but kyle is just a simple florida guy
who loves uh uh booze and trump and uh
so this this episode is brought to you
by steve will do it and by the way he is
hilarious
like his videos are actually very funny
yeah he did a video with dobrik where
like he's gives to david dobrik another
tesla because they had some beef that
wasn't real and they kind of patched it
up and like david dobrik said how much
does this watch and steve will do it
says like very nonchalantly he's like
it's five hundred thousand dollars
straight nonchalant he's like it's 500
so it's this episode is brought to you
by steve will do it the world's number
one youtube channel if you are not
already
aware
steve the prolific front man of the
canadian group the knelt boys you've pre
pre probably seen his videos where he
gave david dobrik a tesla did he write
this himself did he write this like
drunk in a car he might have yeah he
probably wrote this like trunk in a car
just coked out at like a signal like
everybody's like everybody's like
beeping just make go
go he's like shut up
um
he bought a yacht
with 10 million dollars in bitcoin met
donald trump aboard air force one and
donated hundreds of thousands of dollars
to the less fortunate
along with his best friend and
philanthropist takashi 6-9
i mean
i can't make this ad funnier but we do
love steve and i i'm sure he has done
things for the less fortunate with
takashi 69.
check out his happy dad seltzer they
have a new cell sir it's in stores in
florida nevada california and
massachusetts
colle places where people party
steve is also is one of the biggest
emerging fashion brands with full scent
this is true they send me [ __ ] all the
time go to fullsend.com to sign up for
exclusive merch drops everything is
currently sold out and you don't want to
miss out cause these people by the way
when they release merch it's not like me
where i gotta beg my fans to buy it i
gotta beg them like a guy who cheated on
his wife to get back in the door of
their house so he can give his daughter
a birthday present i gotta beg them
and then the merch companies we use are
deadbeats and don't hold that against me
still buy but they're deadbeats and
morons
michael gruen with his [ __ ] you know
his advice
never take merch advice from a guy that
wears a wears a uh undershirt everywhere
michael they make clothes for big people
i'll take you to dxl enough with the
undershirt
go to fullsend.com
to sign up for exclusive uh merch do you
know the nelk video
they have a new now video coming out
with brian laundry
where they said it it's just about
getting [ __ ] up and it's it's called
leaving the past in the past
and it's brian laundry and nell
you know this is good it's brian laundry
and now and they just go and get [ __ ]
up i don't know who this brian laundry
is but he's fun
so go to full send.com because when they
release this merch it sells out
immediately because all these kids like
all my little cousins and people like
that
uh go and buy it and then adults buy it
too
lastly go right now to steve will do it
youtube channel right now and see what
all the
hubbub is about for yourself he drops
new videos every single thursday they
actually are entertaining so go there
hit like and subscribe steve will do it
as literally the craziest channel on
youtube and in comparison makes david
dobrik seem like a docile peasant
that is s-t-e-v-e-w-i-l-l-d-o
[Music]
steve will do it
on youtube
and and he's a fair
friend of this show he's a fan of the
show he helps us all the time
get our name out there we're we're
really excited that he's come on now as
a sponsor of the of the uh tim dillon
show and we're very proud of him uh
going it cuz brian laundry's had a rough
month and i think it's to kneel to
feature him in a video is like cool yeah
and they'll get flack for it they're
gonna get flack for it
because of the pc culture
people are gonna get angry because of pc
culture when they put brian laundry on a
jet ski
and he's you know
just funneling bacardi rum in
in uh cancun or whatever
wherever these people go
so steve will doit.com
what else do we got in terms of
advertisements i bet we've got so much
fun stuff then i want to go over to the
store and see jessica kearson the very
funny jessica kearson who just did joe
rogan show
blue chew how much i mean how many times
i have to tell you blue chew it is the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis it's a chewable it's to help your
peen peen get hard you know you need it
it gives you the confidence you may lack
in the bedroom it's so easy just a
consultation
with a doctor online or some medical
professional
blue chew you go online you get a
referral
uh from an official medical person and
they find out what's right for you in
the dosage and you can take it on a
fuller empty stomach you do whatever you
want to do you do whatever you want to
do with the chew
blue to the chew
and
i'm just telling you right now it's it's
a great thing so if you could uh benefit
from extra confidence in the bedroom
blue chew can help
promo code td try bluetooth free when
you use our promo code td at checkout
just pay five dollars shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code td to receive
your first month free visit bluechew.com
for more details and important safety
information we thank bluetooth for
sponsoring the podcast
gabby insurance is so important it's
crazy how fast the prices of just about
everything right now are rising gas
groceries close you name it and all the
experts are saying it's going to get
worse before it gets better i've been
looking at all the ways i can personally
cut out costs this is true
ways to save where i can i started with
auto insurance i started with gabby
shopping for auto insurance sucks i get
it
so does gambie that's why all they
do works for you things that would take
days or weeks gabby does in minutes
gabby uses your current policy to
compare your coverage with 40 of the top
insurance providers nationwide and
travelers they're the one true
comparison platform with fast
verifiable quotes not ballpark cases and
because gabby uses your current coverage
they only show policies that are the
same or better than your current
coverage many of them at a lower price
and gabby is free to use and they never
sell your info so no annoying spam or
robocalls gabby helped me find the right
policy for my range rover it was great i
logged in with my current insurance
provider i got so many quotes i don't
even know how many a lot and the dollar
amount that gabby saved me
people who switch with gabby save on
average eighty dollars a month first
their current policy it's eighty dollars
okay
it's not just me who loves gabby gabby's
been featured in tech crunch forbes usa
today start saving on your auto
insurance today go to gabby.com tim
dillon to start saving today it's
totally free that's g-a-b-i dot com
slash tim dillon
gabby.com tim dillon let's end this
gangbuster of an episode with a trailer
because you know me and disney plus i
have nothing but great things to say
there is a documentary about
fouchy
um
when the obama's got a netflix deal and
now that um
harry and megan have one
um
it is becoming quite clear
that politicians
are
going to
no longer rely on the hacks
in hollywood and the media to portray
them in a flattering light they are
going to directly get involved with how
their legacies are sculpted it's a
pretty brilliant move uh these people
are directly going to get involved and
influence
public opinion so there is now a
documentary about fouchy now whatever
you think of fouchy
running the gamut from
aids hitler
to
second coming of of vaccine christ
whatever you think about facts saucy
whatever you think about fouchy
this is
wildly unnecessary we are still in the
middle of a pandemic the resources
devoted to making this film should not
have been let's watch the trailer okay
when i think about my dad growing up i
certainly think about that seriousness
but very few people get to see
he's funny weird and really playful
god help us
in 1981 hiv aids was evolving rapidly
and frighteningly there was anger at the
government's response when you got sick
you were gone fast
it's affecting you now yeah why i think
he was good on this i think you know
from what i've heard about
him
on the
aids front i believe he was in a don't
you know how people are going to be like
he created it
you're a liar and i just
i but what i've heard from people that
work
in epidemiology is that he was good on
that he's been a little bit of a klutz
here
if if we want to be
really nice about it you'd call him a
klutz
um
if you wanted to be a meanie you would
call him a liar
and um
someone who
has perhaps twisted the truth to protect
people
um but
klutz would would certainly be not wrong
to call him but let's continue this
stress center
he also loves the spotlight
my dad said we're gonna get through this
whole thing yeah take time
you don't see it because you want to
make money you don't do it for the glory
you do it because you care when you're
involved in a race to stop a horrible
disease
you always feel you're not doing things
quickly enough
[Music]
okay was morbid
it kind of just shows that he kind of
failed like massively well what was he
supposed to do you know completely like
stop aids of course
he's not supposed to do that
um
you know i mean
i guess if you work in that business
like you're always gonna kind of fail
right
you know
he's an interesting guy he's been a
government
he's been the the pandemic guy forever
that's a weird dude
you know
the guy was like you know what gets me
up in the morning what disease
you go okay
stopping it or what
it's like the people that talk about
poverty all the time like do you really
want it to end then what would you do
i work at the center for global poverty
okay and what would you like well
we'd like more global poverty why well
that's kind of what we do
okay it's kind of with disease a little
bit yeah yeah like we don't want to get
rid of all the diseases he's like we
like to you know
we like a little bit of disease a little
bit
makes everything work see that'd be
funny why doesn't disney do that like do
an animated thing where fauci's like
having a little fun with gain of
function research you know he's like a
little bit
makes everything work we need and just
needles like in the background why can't
we have a little fun where are the
talented people behind uh these pictures
we can do something with little music
you know laura who opened for me in
boston works at harvard and loves
fouching so i know that there's people
that love him
and i my problem with him is that he's
an italian an italian and i believe that
we should be represented by an asian or
a jew in the medical field or a
pakistani or someone from india i don't
trust a guy that looks like me talking
about health and i certainly don't trust
a mr meatball
but go check that out for yourself uh
what are they called disney plus what is
it called it's disney plus it's just
called fauci they were shooting a dock
this this whole time i didn't know that
they're like the when we see jake paul
out and about and there's cameras
following him fauci had the same thing
but
fauci is he's epidemiology's jake paul
that's what he is
fouchy is epidemiology's jake paul
you can hate him you can love him but he
ain't going nowhere
that's what it is
you could hate him you could love him
but that man is determined to have his
face splashed you
there's a version of though that goes no
i don't want to do this
there's a version of him that goes
i'm busy
there's a version of him that goes i
don't think it's appropriate
in the middle of a pandemic that was
supposedly serious enough where we had
to
decimate our entire economy i think it
would be odd to do like a puff piece on
me
why don't we wait a few years
but i guess not you just dove right in
he goes here what time i'm gonna be
there nine
should i be makeup i'll be in makeup
already
don't worry about it he's on the phone
he's like cancel the lab i got a thing
now i got all day this is the crew
showing up they're like we'll be quick
he's like no no we i blocked off a week
for this they go really
he goes yeah he goes i'm doing two dope
queens later but right now i have all
the time to talk to you
i'm doing my favorite murder later i'm
going to tell karen kolgariff about the
vaccine
enough with him
timberlandcomedy.com for all live dates
we apologize about milwaukee we moved
the thursday show to sunday flights got
[ __ ] we got [ __ ] we're using a
temporary studio we got [ __ ] out of uh
timberland company.com got all the dates
for the tour we're starting in late
october we're going everywhere
spokane seattle portland indianapolis
morgantown west virginia pittsburgh
washington new york atlantic city
rochester iowa city madison wisconsin
louisville
kentucky
los angeles california bakersfield
california san diego
reading pennsylvania atlanta georgia
we've added second shows in atlanta and
sacramento atlantic city atlantic city
st louis sacramento
um
san francisco
garden city indiana
toronto ontario oh and my favorite iowa
city
is that still happening yeah my favorite
iowa city
we'll just go there and and make the
money so that is on the 18th everybody
go get tickets to the angler theater in
iowa city where there was a big
kerfuffle there was a big uproar
at me doing jokes i guess at the expense
of i don't know nurses
um because we all know that the one
thing heroes can't handle is a guy on a
stage making a a
little joke
they build the heroes from movies being
like you made a joke about me and i'm
not even blaming the nurse this is again
this is uh supposedly because i
questioned the response to the pandemic
i questioned the response to the
pandemic
how orwellian uh there was uh
people were emailing the anglert theater
i don't even know what it is i don't
know what they do with the anglert
theater i'm sure they have some big
comedians and bands go but i don't know
what goes on at the angler theater but
apparently they have a there's a real
thriving arts community in
iowa city
that was unhappy with uh some of the
remarks i've made and by thriving arts
community i mean two people with blue
hair and cats
who sent one email
that seth simons wrote
[Laughter]
timdylandcomedy.com
full send baby goodbye